Speaker 1: With absolutely no delay because
I respect all of you too much to delay any
further. Let's get right into the wacky
political happenings in Warren, Michigan,
that took place over the weekend. Later, we're
going to get into Marjorie Taylor Green's latest
claim that Democrats are out there assassinating
Republicans willy nilly. It's not true. We'll
get to it a little bit later. But where was this
all happening? Well, it was happening in Warren,
Michigan, because failed former President Donald
Trump dripping wet, just the sweat dripping off of
him, more orange than ever, visibly scared about
what is his future in this country in the context
of four or more criminal investigations
against him, dripping, just slathered.
He rallied in Michigan, supposedly in support of
a number of different Republicans. He barely spoke
about them. As is often the case, the rallies are
all about him. One such Republican is Tudor Dixon.
That's her name, Tudor Dixon. And she is getting
crushed right now by the Democratic incumbent
governor, Gretchen Whitmer, despite Trump
attacking Whitmer for the last three years since
COVID started. Trump starts his rally in Warren,
Michigan. He now has a new election hypothesis. He
claims that a guy named John James won his Senate
race in 2020. John James lost his Senate race in
2020. So it's it's not just Trump's election that
now he is lying about with no basis, in fact,
whatsoever he goes, I think John James actually
won. Now you might be like, no, John James isn't
a senator and you'd be right because he lost.
Speaker 4: And somebody that I've known for a
long time, he did great. I think he happened to
win the last election for the Senate. I happen
to think he won it by quite a bit and now he's way
leading. He's doing a fantastic job. He's got the.
Speaker 1: Votes. Yeah. John James lost
his election. He didn't win. Had he won,
he would be a senator right now. Donald Trump also
makes the extraordinarily disturbing comment that
we will never have a fair election again in the
United States. Well, then why would anyone vote?
Speaker 4: But I'm afraid we have never
had we and I don't believe I don't believe
we'll ever have a fair election again.
Speaker 1: Wow. That's a big statement
now. Certainly not if Trump has his say. I mean,
listen, were it for Trump, had Trump gotten his
way in 2020, the president right now would
be the guy who didn't win anything. It would
have it would be the guy who not only lost the
popular vote, lost or lost the electoral vote,
he would be president right now. So when they
say things like this, what we should hear is
them saying, if it's up to us, there will never
be a fair election in this country again. Donald
Trump then still not really knowing much about
dogs. Listen to what he has to say about dogs.
Speaker 4: Now, think of it. They're against
all of those things. The way they win is
to cheat in elections. A cheat like dogs.
Speaker 1: They cheat like dogs. Dogs don't
cheat. Donald Trump, we know his relationship
with our canine friends is clearly very scrambled,
but dogs don't really cheat. Dogs actually
are very much the opposite. Okay. Trump then
suggests that China infected the U.S. with
COVID to punish us because of the tariffs
that Trump put on China, which of course Trump
still doesn't understand, are actually paid by
American companies. The American companies pay
the tariffs when they import Chinese goods.
Speaker 4: We saved many industries. We
took in hundreds of billions of dollars in
tariffs and taxes from China. They did
not like me too much. So I a lot of
people said, I wonder why COVID came here.
Speaker 1: I wonder why that's another it's
another conspiracy theory. The reason COVID came
here. I mean, okay, fine. It started in China
and then it went to Italy and then it
went to London and then eventually it
got here. It was sent by China through many
other countries as punishment for tariffs,
which our own companies paid. It's economics,
guys. Don't you understand what's so confusing
about that? Trump Then lies. And this
is part of like the lurid stories,
part of his rallies. Trump lies that
Democrats support abortion after birth.
But who has ever said that? No one but.
Speaker 4: The radical Democrats believe
in abortion. And really, right from the
moment of birth and even after birth,
you can't let this happen. There's no country
in the world that wants what these crazy people
want. They are radical. They want to.
Speaker 1: Accept it's all not.
Speaker 4: True. Babies from the wombs. Remember
during the debate was crooked Hillary Clinton. I
said they want to rip the baby from the womb
even in the ninth month. Michigan you need
to dump this while die extreme extremist.
Speaker 1: Gretchen Whitmer Yeah Whitmer is
going to win. And of course there are essentially
statistically there are almost no abortions in
the ninth month. Talk to OBGYN. I've done it.
We've done it on the show. We've talked about
it essentially does not happen if a woman comes
in and, you know, 38 weeks pregnant and says,
I think I want an abortion, but you think OB-GYNs
just go, sure, have an abortion. And then,
of course, the the post-birth thing is just
completely fabricated. Trump then says that
they presumably Democrats, I guess, want to
see him in prison. I think they'd like to.
Speaker 4: See me in prison. Can you
imagine? I think that, like, you know why?
You know why? Because they're sick.
Speaker 1: They're sick, sick people.
One of the things that's interesting is these
Republicans love to say they are for law and order
all the time they said were for law and order
were for law and order. My position as someone
on the left is not I want to see Trump in prison.
I'm out for blood. It's if there is evidence that
Trump should be charged, then charge him. And then
if he is convicted, sentence him appropriately.
And maybe that'll include prison time. That's law
and order. Okay. Not what they claim. Trump then
sort of wax poetic about authoritarian Chinese
President Xi, where he talks about how great
it is that he's just killing drug dealers.
Speaker 4: Much of the crime wave is caused
by drug dealers who during their lives will kill
an average of 500 American citizen. Think of it.
Think of it. And I tell the story. I'll tell
it quickly. But when I was dealing with China
and when I was dealing with Russia and our
neighbors dealing with all these countries,
I got to know them all well. And I asked
President Xi, they have 1.5 billion people
and they'd say, is he smart? I say, Yes,
he's smart. Then the press would say,
he's saying President Xi is somebody is the ruler
of 1.5 billion, is smart, very smart. Beyond smart
as a president, do you have a drug problem anyway?
Speaker 1: Then he tells the story of how she told
him that they execute the drug dealers and
they have like a 100% conviction rate. When
I hear about 100% conviction rate, I start
wondering, is that really a fair justice
system? But Trump is completely enamored by
it. Then we get to the big finish, which now
includes a sort of Q and on music backdrop.
This is now a regular part of these rallies.
Speaker 4: In the history of the world.
Speaker 1: I have not added this music
last time. Some of my viewers thought I
added the music. They are now doing this
at the rally.
Speaker 4:
But now we are a nation in decline. We
are a failing nation. We are a nation
that has the highest inflation in 50 years.
Speaker 1: So anyway, why is it that the cults
never have good music? I've noticed that
there's just. The music's always so weird.
We laugh to avoid crying because this is really,
really disturbing and it sort of gets awkward.
At one point during this musical portion of
the speech, when Trump talks about brutal
murders. He loves using these lurid examples of
violence to whining about flight cancelations,
which of course, don't affect him since he
flies private and it's all really awkward.
Speaker 4: Thieves are allowed to go into stores
and openly rob them, beat up the help and kill
people. They will kill people and they will them
at will if necessary and even if not necessary.
And there is no retribution.
Speaker 1: They're doing necessary and
unnecessary killings. Well, if they're necessary,
are they really evil? What does that even mean?
Speaker 4: Very. We are a nation whose once
revered airports are a dirty, crowded mess,
where you sit and wait for hours and then
are notified that the plane won't leave
and they have no idea when they will as a nation.
Speaker 1: Trump also is furious that he has
not gotten credit for some of his recent
flights to his frequent flier miles.
Speaker 4: When they will be delivered and
when you will be delivered to your destination.
Speaker 1: It's all right. I can't I can't do any
more of it. But it's gone completely cultlike and
an extraordinarily dangerous and unhinged speech.
The good news, if there is any, is that a bunch of
the people Trump is supporting in Michigan seem to
be heading towards some pretty humiliating losses.
One last, really funny moment. I believe this was
after the speech, but maybe it was before. And
again, the speech was in Michigan. This guy,
Brian Glenn, who's one of the hosts on right
side Broadcasting Network. This guy, Brian,
has been interviewing Trump for years all over
the country. They go to every rally and Trump
talks to him about your governor, Gretchen
Whitmer, as if he doesn't even recognize
that this is the same dude who is not
from Michigan and he's been interviewing
Trump dozens of times a year. Look at this.
Speaker 4: Sense. The values of the people from
Michigan and your governor has done a very poor
job. As you know, we've lost a lot of business in
Michigan. They've lost a lot of jobs in Michigan.
I think Twitter is going to do very well.
Speaker 3: Mr. President, always a pleasure.
Speaker 1: So anyway, Trump doesn't even
seem to know who is talking about
their scary stuff. But remember,
it's always scarier that people follow this stuff.
And that's what we're going to talk about next